my name is Weston mekonnen I'm the
managing director of a new office here
in Ethiopia that hv opened up 1.1 change
for the one year I mean European as well
as Africans when an importer of goods or
many many many years we all know it it's
about time that we become exported of
something and the one thing that I think
we can do almost immediately is in ICT
why if you think about it to generate a
software all you really need is a desk a
desktop and a brain that can have the
freedom to think about things that
others haven't thought about it yeah and
now that becomes something we can easily
export don't need no infrastructure all
you need is just a sin and that software
could be available somewhere out there
so it could be a major way to change
this paradigm of Africa being known as
the importers of good and televisions
cars you can go on and to now have this
leap frogging into exporter of something
that is becoming crucial to the world
today that is generation of data content
software's ways to do things different
great examples already in Africa this is
what we each and every one of us can
start doing thank you very much